thank you to hellotalk for sponsoring
this video okay hey everyone and welcome
to the fourth episode of a japanese
teacher graduate japanese today we're
going to be looking at just one person's
japanese
and there's kind of a special reason for
that but i'll get into that in a second
so today we're going to be looking at
shusang's japanese so
let's just start watching
us
japanese teacher grades are japanese
the first thing i want to say about your
japanese is that it's
really really really good phonetically
speaking
particularly i think that your
pronunciation is phenomenal i'm
not kidding when i say that i think that
your pronunciation is probably better
than my pronunciation
so if we can just fix a couple things
related to your pitch accent then i
think that
overall your spoken japanese will sound
more natural than my my spoken japanese
right before
uh talking about the phonetic side of
things i i would like to mention that
it's
i think that in the video we started out
with kind of the more
polite forms of japanese
but then somewhere towards the middle i
think you said uh
so you kind of switched into more casual
japanese i would
try and be uh aware of this because
obviously there are uh elements of
spoken japanese pronunciation and pitch
acts and that when japanese people hear
it kind of sounds unnatural to them
but even more than that i think that
most japanese people
probably would be more conscious of a
switch from
polite japanese into casual japanese and
then a switch back
so i think that your japanese is uh
certainly good enough
to know what i'm talking about so that
would just be one thing that i'd be
aware of
rather than saying
it might be better it would probably be
better to say like
or something like that so um that's just
kind of point one but let's get into the
phonetic side of things and this is
actually where i'm i'm really excited
right now because um i purposely chose
your video because the first time i
i watched on watched it on twitter i
noticed
that you said one of the words in the
video in an inc
in the incorrect way and there's
actually a rule if you know
you'll essentially never make a mistake
for that kind of word you'll never
mispronounce that kind of word again
this is one of the many kind of really
really important
uh phonetic pitch accent rules that i
teach on on patreon so this is the rule
memorize this everyone watching you got
to memorize this a very high percentage
a
very high percentage of four maura so
kind of four
beat nouns in japanese that have
two kanji or chinese characters
their pitch accent pattern is flat so
they have the herbang
pitch accent pattern so in kind of
slower more deliberate speech it kind of
starts slow goes up a little bit and
then it's kind of more or less flat
throughout the word but in normal
everyday speech this pattern is
basically
essentially flat in your video i was
able to pick up on
this because you said the word for
education
which is spelled like this i'll put it
up on screen right now
but i believe that you said
at the beginning of the word but this is
a perfect example
of a word that falls into this that
abides by this rule so it's got
two kanji two chinese characters right
and
four kanji
so the kyo is is there's two characters
there but kyo is only
one beat and then is also one beat eat
one beat and then
one beat as well four more two kanji
noun so it's actually not
kyoyko but more or less flat
so it's actually not but
more or less flat and there are
so so so many words again that fall into
this pattern
and just by knowing this single pattern
you immediately know
the correct pronunciation the correct
pitch accent for literally hundreds of
of everyday nouns in japanese just by
knowing this one single rule
so i made it kind of a little list of a
bunch of everyday rules
uh everyday nouns that abide by this
rule because they fall into this
structure and also have this pitch
accent so
let's just go down this list right now
as in school
daigaku as in university
as in high school as in student being
as in studies gingko as in bank
as in the worst or the lowest sayaku
as in the worst kobang as in police
station
as in practice shimbai as in worry
and literally hundreds i don't know the
exact number but certainly at least a
hundred more other
100 more nouns that fall into this
pattern
and have this word structure have this
pitch accent pattern as well so by
listening to how many
everyday nouns i just said that fall
into this pattern it's kind of
mind-blowing right it's kind of like
wait a second it's not gaku but
and it's not daigaku but daigo
that's exactly right you can
accurately to a very high degree
assume that nouns in japanese that have
four mora and
two kanji fall into this pattern now i
say to a high degree because there are
exceptions to this rule but because
there are so many words that abide by
this rule
you can just memorize the common
everyday exceptions and then assume that
all other words that aren't in that
exceptions
are going to abide by the rule and and
it will immediately
increase again uh your
kind of japanese pronunciation batting
average
so to speak this single rule by knowing
it it will
instantly improve the naturalness of
your spoken japanese so
let's go over some of the exceptions
right now
this is for mora as well and two kanji
as you can see but it's not
so yeah music if i didn't say that
kyodai as in
a sibling sensei as in um
teacher it's not sensei and it's not
sensei
it's sensei onnai as in to show or to
guide
zaan nen as in unfortunate cudio
as in uh salary and then what was there
was another one
as in sorry i forgot to write like three
or four common ones down
me
as in kind of the entryway to someone's
house in a japanese house and then also
uh keizai keizai as in um
economics besides those kind of
exceptions that i've just listed right
now
i've i basically believe that it's safe
to assume that
all other four more nouns
uh in japanese that have two kanji will
fall into this hey bomb pattern and
again when you assume this
overnight you stop saying like literally
hundreds of everyday nouns
wrong especially for a native english
speaker and you've been saying all these
words as like
gakuse or
your spoken japanese again your
pronunciation i literally think is
already better than mine
so if you just memorize this rule i
would say that probably most
japanese people and you like really get
this rule into your bones so to speak
i think that you'll get to a point in no
time at all where your spoken japanese
sounds better than my spoken japanese so
as mentioned earlier hellotalk sponsored
this video so i'm going to
kind of take a couple minutes and just
introduce their service for those that
don't know hellotalk is a
language learning application that
allows you to
directly interact with native speakers
of that language i've talked about this
a little bit in the past but for a very
very long time i used
a service called language8.com and
on that website what you would do is you
would write something in japanese
and then native japanese speakers would
correct it
and then you would in turn correct their
english hello talk is kind of like that
but it's better because you can actually
record yourself speaking japanese and
then get direct
native input essentially instantly which
i think is extremely valuable so now i'm
going to try and do
is make a little recording of five of
the words that i said
that i said earlier with the correct
pitch accent let's try and say them with
the wrong pitch accent and see if we can
get a native speaker to correct those so
i'm going to click the mic and make a
little recording
university daigon
okay so i'm going to try and post this
right now and we'll see how long it
takes to get a native response looks
like i got a response i got a response
10 minutes after i i posted the video
there are
a couple of japanese speakers that are
just saying to them
which is kind of a cultural thing but
one of the responses that i got
has explicitly uh written down the pitch
accent of all the words
and this guy actually also he gave a
recording of the correct
uh paychecks and of all the words so
let's listen to that real quick if you
want to pronounce them in tokyo accent
they should be
psycho
so there you go that's the four more
rule in action
obviously this is extremely extremely
valuable for people that are actively
trying and trying to
improve their japanese pitch accent and
and pronunciation and then there's a
bunch of really cool features
such as auto translate and you can hold
long words that are in japanese and it
will switch them
into no maji so roman characters if
you're just starting to study japanese
and you can't read
kanji and hiragana yet so that's
obviously very useful you can use it for
free and then they've got special vip
accounts as well so there's some perks
involved there but i would encourage
everyone watching to at least check the
application out if you haven't already
especially if you're studying japanese
and you're trying to improve your spoken
japanese so
check out hello talk thank you again to
hellotalk for sponsoring this video and
let's get back to
shoes on japanese there's kind of good
evidence that you're already starting to
say
that you already kind of have a okay
understanding of japanese pitch accent
and that's because
there were there was at least one word
in the video that
most native english speakers i think
that your native english speaker or at
least
english is one of your first languages
because you said that you went back to
toronto which is obviously
an english area but you said um
which is the word for video in japanese
and most native english speakers who've
never studied page accent
will pronounce this word as dolga dolga
with the accent
excuse me at the beginning of the word
this isn't is not an example of
a word that falls into the rule that we
covered earlier but it is an example of
a word
that that falls into that general
category that we introduced in a couple
videos ago and that's that
about half of three mora nouns
in japanese don't have an accent so
they're also hebong
so it's not doga again it's
and you said that the correct way so
you're already off to a decent start in
terms of paychecks and i assume that
you've never studied it before it sounds
like
you haven't in terms of not not your
your accent but
by what you said um so
combine that with the rule that i just
explained and you're going to be in just
this
absolutely incredible place and you're
beyond your pronunciation you're really
articulating your thoughts in a really
really natural manner
and except for that kind of one very
small minor thing when you said
i think that essentially there was no
other kind of major things that stood
out to me
uh in terms of well non-phonetic issues
i saw that there was one more thing that
i was going to say oh
it also sounded to me like you were
saying the word for japanese
japanese language as uh nihongo with the
accent on the
on the whole now
now and i've kind of talked about this
in previous videos so i won't i believe
i talked about it in
actually in lesson one so i'll just
leave a link
to that below so if people want to well
it's not nihongo but
nihongo it's more or less
again another bong word so i'll leave a
link to that video below
but again shoot a song you're off to an
incredible start and if you just
um well for now i would say just
concentrate on memorizing that single
rule that i've introduced today
if you do that you'll be in an
absolutely incredible place
in no time at all especially because
this rule is so easy to understand that
uh you'll be able to again immediately
improve your japanese basically
overnight just by learning the rules so
so
um i think i'm going to end the video
here in this video i primarily
wanted to cover the formula to kanji
noun rule and that's because again when
i listened to shusan's video on
on twitter i heard and i thought okay
this is the perfect opportunity for me
to introduce
introduce that rule which is so
important so everyone watching
memorize this rule it's incredibly
important
if you would like to sound as native as
possible
if you would like me to phonetically
analyze your japanese you can send me a
video on twitter
at dogan d-o-g-e-n and
please embed the video such that i can
watch it immediately
please also provide a download link so
that i can such that i can download the
original
version with the original quality then
if you can also add add
subtitles that helps with um well that
helps for people that are just starting
to learn japanese right now and maybe
they don't have
they uh it's more difficult for them to
understand exactly what's going on
incidentally the next video i'm going to
put out is going to be a return to kind
of the normal comedic style video so
expect that
and then also thank you again very much
to
hellotalk for sponsoring this video so
i'm going to end things here thank you
all very much for
thank you all very much for your
continued support and i'll see you again
soon